hola bienvenidos bueno aquí se nos piden
determina una función de la forma ya
igual a seno de equis o ye igual a un
coste no debe x representada por la
gráfica y tenemos que averiguar lo que
son las así las ves y es una función se
no es una función coseno entonces lo
primero que yo noté es que cualquiera
sea esta función cuando x es igual a 0
no es igual a 0 es igual a menos 2 y
basándonos en eso basándonos en lo que
ya sabemos de funciones seno y cosenos
crees tú que esto tendrá la forma de
igualar seno de x o que tendrá la forma
e igual a coste no debe x y esto sin
saber que que son las así las veces no
sabemos qué es eso pero será ésta una
función de xenón o coseno y hay que
pensar en esto en que es seno de cero
entonces tomando seno de cero ya sabemos
que eso es igual a cero entonces esto es
igual a cero
y que es coseno de 0 coseno de 0 es
igual a 1 así que sería muy difícil
especialmente en esta forma sería
imposible si seno de cero es cero
entonces bueno multiplicar por cero algo
para llegar a menos 2 no tiene mucho
sentido porque 0 por lo que sea es 0 por
lo tanto aquí y aquí no puede ser una
función seno no puede tener esa forma
tal vez tú digas bueno coseno de cero es
1 pero aquí hay un -2 eso es una muy
buena observación si tú tienes uno lo
puedes multiplicar por algo para obtener
menos dos cierto entonces lo que sí
sabemos es que tenemos esta forma igual
a coseno dvx ye igual a coseno de x pero
falta algo falta algo muy importante ver
que representan las así las veces no hay
que olvidarnos de eso sabemos que ésta
es una función igual a kossen no debe xy
la siguiente pregunta que yo tengo para
ti es
es la que representa pensemos en eso si
tuviéramos bueno vimos que si tuviéramos
coste no debe x solamente cuando x es
igual a cero
jose no debe por cero simplemente sería
coseno de cero y eso nos lleva a 1 pero
no estamos en uno estamos en menos 2
entonces tomamos una función con xenon y
cuando x es igual a 0 lo multiplicamos
por menos 2 y de esta forma esto tendría
que ser menos 2 ya tenemos un poco más
información sabemos que tenemos de igual
a menos 2 coseno dvx ye igual a menos 2
coseno de v x y bueno hasta ahora que
podemos ver aquí podemos ver que la
amplitud que la distancia desde el valor
máximo que sería este valor el valor
máximo hasta el valor mínimo es 4 y la
mitad de eso es 2 o podríamos también
pensarlo como dos unidades desde el
punto del centro
y aquí si piensas en la amplitud la
amplitud es el valor absoluto de este
número
entonces la amplitud es igual al valor
absoluto de menos 2 y lo cual es en
efecto 2 así que hasta este momento es
consistente lo que hacemos y ahora
pensemos en b que es b
sería bueno usar nuestro conocimiento de
periodo de lo que es un periodo de una
función periódica y pensemos en b que es
b veamos aquí cuál es el periodo el
periodo de esta función periódica
dibujemos un ciclo
entonces si este es nuestro punto de
partida esto es lo que vemos como un
ciclo en dos pisos sobre tres vamos a
llegar aquí hasta dos pisos sobre tres
como lo puedes ver ya completamos un
ciclo aquí ajá luego podríamos empezar
con el siguiente ciclo repetimos el
patrón una y otra y otra vez así
seguimos entonces basándonos en eso cuál
es el periodo es justamente la distancia
que debe recorrer en x para completar un
ciclo esta distancia puedes ver que es 2
pies sobre 3
por lo tanto el periodo es igual a 2 y
sobre 3 y ahora am
dada esta información podemos podemos
ahora sí saber lo que ve es bueno
pensemos un poco
pensemos el periodo de esto sería igual
sería igual a 2 espn sobre el valor
absoluto de b
sobre el valor absoluto de b y podemos
resolver esto de múltiples maneras
multiplicamos ambos lados por 3 y el
valor absoluto de ben y bueno que nos va
a quedar nos queda que el valor absoluto
de bell es igual a 3 entonces el valor
absoluto de b es igual a 3 lo cual
quiere decir que b puede ser igual a más
o menos 3 entonces b es igual a 3
positivo 3 negativo y tal vez te
preguntas bueno cual usó el 3 positivo o
el 3 negativo muy buena pregunta otra
vez y lo siguiente que te voy a
preguntar es para una función coseno tú
tienes diferentes valores si yo te tengo
aquí si yo tengo coseno de 3x coseno de
es así tengo coseno de menos 3 me
equivoqué es coseno de menos 3 x
obtienes diferentes valores si jugamos
juguemos un poco en el círculo unitario
voy a dibujar acá un pequeño círculo
unitario y recuerda que que el coche no
es la coordenada x donde inter secamos
al círculo unitario ahora sí si nos
movemos en dirección positiva nuestra
coordenada x inicia en 1 luego se hace
más pequeña cuando nos movemos entonces
puedes experimentar con esto y podrás
ver que coseno de 3x ahora bueno cabe
mencionar que esto sólo es válido para
la función coseno y no para la función
seno entonces coseno de 3x es igual a
coseno de menos 3 x así que puedes
elegir cualquiera de los dos ya sea 3x o
menos 3x el que te guste pero bueno yo
por simplicidad voy a elegir el caso
positivo así que yo me voy con el 3
positivo y esto podría hacer la gráfica
por lo tanto dejé
a menos dos por el coche no el coche nos
dice que no hay el negativo entonces de
13 x igual a menos 2 por el coste no de
3x y hemos terminado nos vemos pronto